very nice time yesterday hanging with an
old
uh cohort of yours stephen young he was
on the program
and we were chatting and stephen and i
have been tight over the years and i've
always thought
i found out that you were coming on the
show today and i got i found myself
tightening up a little bit and feeling
and feeling
hostile towards you and then i was like
what is that all about and then i
remembered oh yeah
jeffrey murdered my friend i did
you murdered my friend but you know what
in
thinking about this and i need to talk
to stephen about it i feel like i should
get like an assist
on the academy award nomination because
had i not tapped him with that baseball
bat
he'd still be on the show and now look
at him now he's all
uh in the spotlight big star and
doing brilliant work so you know it's
funny because it did occur to me that
you probably did him a favor you uh you
know he did like seven eight seasons on
that show
you came along and you said it's time
for you time for you to do some uh
oscar nominated performances and movies
i'm talking about go out there and get
up
yeah you you practiced you you you
you've honed your craft here on the
walking dead now
go be free you know i don't i'm i'm uh
you know in a similar vein uh you um
i never even realized this but
you had a scene which is one of the most
memorable scenes in the history
of the walking dead where you
also kill a very beloved character
and i didn't realize this was a
improvised line there was an
improvised line in this scene you know
this you know the line i'm talking about
i know what you're talking about i mean
it's kind of the same scene that uh
yeah that we lost the glenn in um
you are talking about a line improvised
by
the one and only michael cutlets yes i
believe
yeah that's an infamous line and
you guys should be in the writer's guild
because he improvised this line and then
you
improvised your reaction to it can you
take us through that yeah can you take
us through that in
that moment well it's kind of uh you
know in the middle of
negan's introduction and his huge
monologue where he
kind of uh kills glenn or kills abraham
first
yep um and so in the middle of this
monologue uh abraham uh michael cutlet
says
uh suck my to negan
uh or maybe to jeff what you know
and then i you know we had rehearsed it
and never heard the sucker
so when the cameras were rolling he
threw that out and i started laughing um
all of which made the scene i started
giggling and i
looked at everyone else in the lineup
and i'm like did you hear what he just
said he just said suck
mine um and so they kept that all
and sucked my has kind of become
michael's
thing um and now we go to like we'll do
an occasional convention
or i just get stuff sent here to sign
comic books or baseball bats or whatever
it may be
and sometimes they have the whole cast
so it'll go to someone's house first if
it goes to cutlets house first before me
he writes always suck my mother
um so that has become his little thing
can you imagine
what it's like to be him because
wherever he goes in the world because
we're talking about a world famous uh
show you can't go anywhere on the globe
and people don't know walking dead
anywhere uh michael cutlets goes uh
people point to him in any language and
say suck my
and that's his life that's his life
that's it
forever or that'll never go away suck my
in every language in every country boom